es steht ziemlich schlecht um die erde
eine forschungsgruppe hat jetzt
simuliert was mit unserer zivilisation
und der erde passieren wird und sie
haben sich auch den wahrscheinlichen
entwicklungsverlauf von außerirdischen
zivilisationen vorgenommen und das
ergebnis ist ja man muss sagen
katastrophal demnach läuft alles auf
eine große katastrophe nahezu
unausweichlich zu und das könnte auch
erklären warum wir bisher keine
außerirdischen zivilisationen gefunden
haben warum weshalb wieso jetzt sind
klicks zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir leben in einem neuen erdzeitalter
dem anthropozän antrieb kommt dabei vom
mensch aus dem griechischen und geologen
sind sich inzwischen sicher dass die
entwicklung in geologischen dimensionen
spätestens seit der mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts menschen
gemacht sind wir verändern die erde
seitdem massiv und steuern sie auf eine
dramatische entwicklung in ein
forschungsteam wollte nun wissen wohin
sich das ganze entwickelt und wenn man
sich den untergang von der einen oder
anderen zivilisation oder kultur hier
auf der erde ansieht dann spricht schon
einiges dafür fast keine kultur hat
irgendwie nachhaltig gewirtschaftet die
menschen verhalten sich da absolut wie
im kindergarten beispiel kapstadt in
südafrika
dabei gibt es bald kaum noch wasser in
chile ist eine ganze bucht auch ganz
ausgetrocknet weil die menschen ihr das
wasser abgegraben haben im iran gibt es
in einigen jahren auch kein wasser mehr
weite teile des landes werden
unbewohnbar und die menschen ja die
machen einfach nichts um es aufzuhalten
beim klimawandel im großen stil aber ist
das singt oder sind wir nur zu blöd das
forschungs 7 oben denn frank von der
university of rochester wollte wissen
was anderswo passiert sein könnte und
uns hier auf der erde noch bevorsteht
dafür schaut sich die forschungsgruppe
die klimaentwicklung von verschiedenen
planeten an und kombinierten sie mit den
erkenntnissen der population biologie
und der ablauf scheint immer derselbe zu
sein die energieressourcen des
heimatplaneten werden demnach immer bis
zu den grenzen ausgeschöpft und führen
zu einer ungebremsten vermehrung der
spezies und der steigende energiebedarf
hat folgen für den planeten unter
passiert und zwar folgendes und zwar
nahezu zwangsläufig der heime planet
wird aus seinem gleichgewicht gebracht
um kollabiert 70 prozent der bevölkerung
sterben als folge dieser entwicklung in
einer zweite möglichkeit wird die
dramatische entwicklung abgebremst es
kommt nicht zu einem massensterben und
im dritten szenario stirbt die ganze
spezies aus und aber spielt es überhaupt
keine rolle ob die zivilisation auf
regenerative energien umsteigt oder
nicht die bevölkerungsentwicklung an
sich die zerstört dem planeten am ende
und sich selbst
mit zudem kommt der umstieg zu spät der
planet hat vorher schon den point of no
return erreicht den punkt ohne
wiederkehr dem forschungsteam ist die
begrenztheit der studie bewusst aber sie
zeigt deutlich auf vor welcher riesigen
herausforderungen jede zivilisation
steht und wie groß das risiko der
selbstvernichtung ist ja inklusive das
heimat planet der klimawandel quasi ein
test um zu prüfen ob die zivilisation
sich wirklich weiterentwickeln kann
besteht sie den test nicht stirbt sie
aus und jetzt habe ich noch etwas ganz
besonderes vor witz 1 der wissenschafts
videowettbewerb ist wieder angelaufen
und ihr habt noch bis zum 30 juni zeit
eure beiträge einzureichen insgesamt
gibt es acht 21.000 euro zu gewinnen
hammer ja der link zum wettbewerb der
ist unten in der video beschreibung
einfach draufklicken und unbedingt
mitmachen auf unserem disco server
erkenne ich übrigens gerne jedem wasser
beachten muss um bessere chancen zu
haben
da hin kommt ihr über den messenger
dafür hier draufklicken man am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal klick zum
social media abonnieren da erfahre das
neueste aus der social media welt aber
nicht die genau glocke vergessen wenn er
hier drauf klingt und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
aliens können wir sie leichter finden
bis dann bleib dran